*inaudible audience speaking*
Mark: I can't hear a word you're saying.
*audience laughing*
*Member of audience says something*
Mark: Yes.
I met you in the dark
You lit me up
You make me feel as though
I was enough
We danced the night away
We drank too much
I held your hair back when
You were throwing up
Then you smiled over your shoulder
For a minute I was stone-cold sober
I pulled you closer to my chest...
Then you asked me to stay over,
I said I already told ya,
I think that you should get some rest
I knew I loved you then
But you'd never know
'Cause I played it cool when I was scared of letting go
I know I needed you
But I never showed
But I wanna stay with you
Until we're grey and old
Just say you won't let go
I'll wake you up with some
Breakfast in bed
I'll bring you coffee
With a kiss on your head
I'll take the kids to school
Wave them goodbye
And I'll thank my lucky stars
For that night
When you looked over your shoulder
For a minute, I forgot that we're older
I wanna dance with you right now
And you look as beautiful as ever
And I swear that everyday you'll get better
You make me feel this way somehow
I'm so in love with you
And I hope you know
Darling your love is more than worth it's weight in gold
We`ve come so far my dear
Look how we've grown
And I wanna live with you until we`re grey and old
Just say you won`t let go
I wanna live with you
Even when we`re ghosts
`Cause you were always there for me when I needed you most
I`m gonna love you till
My lungs give out
I promise till death we part like in our vows
So I wrote this song for you
Now everybody knows
That it's just you and me until we`re grey and old
Just say you won't let go
Ohhh ohh
Just say you won't let gooo
*Audience applause and screaming*
A few hiccups there but uhh
a long way since the first time
I played that song on stage for you guys
*GREAT JOB MARK!*